les champs de blé qui brûle dans le
donbass ces images fournies par les
services de secours d'urgence de la
région sont devenues familières les
fermiers savent qu'après des semaines de
forte chaleur leur culture sont
vulnérables mais ils n'ont aucun doute
quant à la cause des incendies
bombardements regardez vous pouvez
toujours voir les requêtes 2 3 4 on a
perdu à peu près 500 tonnes au prix de
l'année dernière
les armes utilisées sont des roquettes à
sous munitions des conteneurs remplis de
projectiles explosifs
de quelle catégorie exactement l'enquète
le montrera mais c'est à cause de ce
type d'engin que nous sommes dans la
situation que vous voyez ils font exprès
de brûler nos champs
les frappes sont elles intentionnelle ou
les bonbons tel mille feux aux cultures
en ratant leur cible si incendié
deschamps ne représente aucun intérêt
tactique en soi l'agriculture est vital
pour l'économie ukrainienne
soudain oleksy électeurs nous demande de
partir
les bombardements reprennent il faut
quitter les lieux je pense qu'il vise
les lignes à haute tension
donc là c'est pied au plancher c'est moi
nous ralentissons à la proche d'un
village qui a lui même subi des
bombardements
ici olexi confié victor un chargement
humanitaire que ce dernier devra
distribuer à d'autres fermiers plus près
du front
il y à des attaques tous les jours
on fait ce qu'on peut
on va quand même au boulot il faut bien
moissonnée malgré le danger les derniers
chiffres officiels montrent une
augmentation de l'intensité et de la
fréquence des freins d'après les
services de secours d'urgence de la
région de donetsk depuis le 29 juin
dernier il ya eu plus de 55 incendies
qui ont détruit près de 1000 hectares de
cultures